all right jimmy
how's it going welcome back man so you
you i sent you back to colorado or up to
colorado
across to colorado yeah sure uh it's
been like two months now right
almost four is that right yeah march 7th
i left oh wow okay and you you went to
rehab and
yep stayed the whole time this is denver
or boulder
huh where were you at yeah like right
it's like a little
a little city next to denver denver and
uh
so so you've stopped using fentanyl yeah
i've been since the day i left
wow how has that been it was tough at
first
but when i got there it was real easy
because i
it was you know usually out here it's a
mental game because i know i can go get
it
out there you know everyone the the
whole
the whole the whole program was in
wanted to be clean
clean and [ __ ] so it was like a lot
easier and like and i knew i couldn't
get it
and the subutex and they're in the value
and [ __ ] helped a lot
so the subutex does what it it
it takes away your cravings
it um you know it's just
it's like it's it's kind of like a
supplement for like heroin
and fendal because you do get sick off
them which is the shitty part
but you're one of only two people that
i've out of the three thousand
not that they're all addicts but a lot
of the people i interview are drug
addicts
you're the only you and you and alex are
from chicago are the only two people i
know of that have
made any progress with getting off of
fentanyl they can do it
it's all they got it's all it's just
they just got to put their mind to it
you know like i said
the first time you know you know when
you're done like you know when you're
ready to do it
like you know you just gotta be
you just gotta be do the mission like
the first time i got clean remember i
told you i took a five-day train here
just out of nowhere just because i
wanted to get clean
five-day training from florida and i was
thinking
i was sick of living with no money and
not doing nothing yeah
you would come over to my studio and
just be like like just
crying and miserable yeah that was just
me walking one day
literally it's just so much pressure
built up i didn't even wasn't even
planning to come here
and i i was just so much pressure built
up
we weren't even talking i just started
[ __ ] just volunteers
yeah but i saw how miserable you were
yeah and it made
it you know i don't see a whole lot of
people react that way yeah and that you
were saying you wanted to
get get out of here get get clean and
get your life straight and all that and
i'm like [ __ ] if there's ever a good
candidate to help out
yeah i really appreciate you like
you made it happen man like honestly
like without without you i honestly i
probably would still be out here
you know no i mean it's very easy to get
behind somebody like yourself who
who you just tell your your head and
your heart were in the right place you
wanted to do the right thing and
it's nice to see a little result you put
on some weight which is great yeah i'm
like 220 now i was probably like 170 180
back then that's great
and uh so what's your next step now
uh going to oregon get a nice little job
22 an hour is that right yeah so you got
you got
a nice job lined up yeah thanks to my
father
he like yeah he got a couple friends you
know
around the country he's like you know go
to vegas or go
to oregon you know because like i was
getting bored of colorado you know
yeah well there's always say yeah i
would say keep saying you know they're
making fun of me in the comments
you guys don't know but no but
yeah but yeah oregon's the next step so
you were reading some of the comments on
your videos yeah read them all tomorrow
i reply to almost all of them i like
them
i like them you know even the bad ones i
said you know i'll say bro like you know
i pray for you bro like you know
get your mind right like because what
do you what do you think most of the
people that make comments on your video
i cried i cry almost almost every time i
read them bro because it's so supportive
yeah a lot of people are so supportive
very much behind you and it's and i
watch a couple other videos and it's not
really
much like that there's some but like it
did they went crazy on my video yeah
you seem very sincere and very like just
ready to do the first time i watched it
when i was out here man i cried for
hours just reading i'm just reading i'm
just
reading and it's like wow this many
people care about me you know
and like they see something in me
i don't know it was insane
yeah i helped a lot too it's nice to be
to feel supported right yeah exactly
it's nice if somebody believes in you
yes yeah yeah
i always i appreciate the stuff you
helped me out with too
always you know i'm talking about yeah
but um so oregon's great that's a
wonderful plan for you yeah never been
there
that's right yeah yeah that's beautiful
up there
so yeah yeah oregon's a nice place to
settle down and and i got some
a little weed it changed your life you
still
you still smoke weed does that help you
with anything yeah it does
i don't know not like a lot but like
maybe a couple times a month
like you know but tell me about trying
to get off of fentanyl what is this like
well the
the first day it's it's not that bad
because it's still in my system
when i wake up it's terrible my my game
is going crazy
oh i need to leave i can go catch a bus
right now
downtown i i can find someone with dope
on craigslist this and that
and then and just give it two three days
of the subs and you you'll feel like a
whole new man you're gonna be like why
the [ __ ] was i on that [ __ ]
you know and i it's happened every
single time that i
that i went to treatment you know and
this is the longest i've actually
stayed and made it clean you know that's
all right yeah
besides the one time on probation which
was nine months but
i was snoring the blue hit when every
once in a while you know
so it's not really so you're still
motivated to stay on track and yeah
that's wrong that's why i'm not that's
why i'm not staying here
yeah i have a surprise to see you a
three-day trip yeah
denver three days here three days and
then i'm going to oregon except my
girl's going back
her way your girlfriend is here yeah she
yeah she's up in the hotel i was
actually
at the uh what's it called on though
wesley clinic getting my suboxone
pressure oh i say so you're just here
getting yours
yeah and they said and they said you're
uh you're late so
the doctor's going on lunch so you have
an hour so i'm like all right i'm gonna
go see mark
oh there you go good so get out of here
as soon as you're done here yeah
don't don't spend any time no no i'm
just gonna be in the hotel room
but even on suboxone the cravings i mean
you
even if you did use nothing would happen
right no well
subby tags subutaxia it can use you
can't use but i'm thinking some boxing
it's a boxing yeah
yeah subutex doesn't have the the locks
on
so like you you can get eye on it and
then the thing is like some people
they'll get high on it and like they
won't get as high as they think they're
going to get and they'll keep doing it
no
d yeah but
but the naloxone but it will authority
in precipi the subutex
won't i mean some people say it won't
throw in precipitator withdrawal
but personally in my experience it has i
don't know if you know what that means
but like
if you do drugs if you do uh opiates
before
the like 40 out 48 hour period or 72
hour period everybody's bites the body's
different
you'll it'd be the worst sickness ever
it was the worst i've done it twice and
it's the worst sickness ever
way worse than me dope sick this is
insane
i had an ama out of a treatment center
one time and go get high just
because it was so bad i was throwing up
blood the doctor told me to eat some
chicken noodle soup
i'm like oh i'm leaving
this wasn't very nice well jimmy i'm so
proud of you
yeah thank you mark great to see you
again and i'm you look great great to
see you
yeah appreciate it mark it was you're
all part of the plan
you you helped you put it in motion and
you know
still you still are hope you know you
still helped me
yeah no i don't think about you every
day honestly bro it's encouraged me to
hear these stories and just not do
anything
especially cases like yours yeah right
where i see hope you know it's it's just
nice to see somebody who wants to do
some of the work on their end
yeah i wish i'd like you i wish i could
do more for other people but i feel like
i'm still not ready
no no you're still noticing yeah i got
to get at least two years
clean yeah or you're still young
23. 23. 24. let's turn 24 september 1st
yeah so get a nice job going get
something come
stay on track i want to get like a
little farm maybe
or something cool yeah i don't know
i just like my peace i don't like l.a i
did the la to chicago like
nah i like my piece you know
well it's nice to see a success story
thank you like yourself so
stay on track and uh we'll do another
one of these down the road baby yeah
sure all right jimmy
great to see you thanks mark thanks
you